it's time for roses and rose hey you
guys I'm wearing a winter hat
es lend why because as of today we are
officially one month away from Bachelor
Winter Games and I could not be more
excited I am so excited you guys I'm
more excited than I am for the actual
Olympics is that weird is that
anti-america but we do have everything
you need to know about it so far that's
uppity TMI com shameless plug okay I
just want to drink hmm are you liking
this season so far let me know in the
comments last week we did kind of a
Becca vs. Becca poll and by the way I
still love both of them are you liking
this season I think that this season has
been very real and not as much drama I
guess it's a question of taste you guys
last week you met JC JC is our wonderful
editor he edits all the roses and Rosie
videos my partner in crime my work hubby
and he is loving this season so are you
team JC or team L Z and that's me JC
thanks that this season which by the way
is the first one that he's ever fully
watched all the way through is like so
grounded and JC's the same age as Ari so
he really relates to him and he thinks
it's really real and he thinks that
Krystal is a good villain but I'm like
I'm like I'm like it's not enough for me
I don't know let's get into it
okay this week we are going to drink
every time we relate to one of the girls
because this season is very grounded and
relatable so first one girl says quote
I'm emotionally and physically drained
me too babe
then Jacqueline is about to go and do
the wrestling a group date and she's
like quote I'm not athletic at all
me too babe I have never wrestled in my
entire life
and it's kind of terrifying I agree babe
[Music]
Ari says that this date is like awesome
women glamorous women glamorous ladies
of wrestling of The Bachelor - the glob
the gorgeous ladies of the bachelor
rustling he says that this is gonna be
so fun because everybody's uncomfortable
okay I would have definitely been
uncomfortable that they're doing I have
dangerous dates this season that's the
thing for the danger factor like between
the demolition derby and this wrestling
thing or they're slamming each other to
the ground it's not a drama considering
the danger the most the most traumatized
girls that Annelise girl we're gonna get
into jana how do you spell that bi bi
ena does your mom know how to spell when
she gave you that name it just doesn't
even make sense with some former ladies
from wrestling come on the show who are
these people I don't know re good
kissing
you guys I cannot anymore I'm not gonna
mention it again because I wish they
wouldn't i cannot again mention that re
is the kissing bandit and then he has
pillow lips and done we're moving
forward with a new narrative okay
there's got to be a new something so
yeah this date looks really scary and I
don't really know who won or not
whatever and then re and Becca JC's
favorite that got shorter Becca talked
and you know they say profound things
like re says that can happen in a
relationship you know let's use it over
some time just like a relief breakup
you're not okay a drink every time you
can relate I mean it's like being like
sometimes meet your full sometimes gonna
eat you're still hungry actually all the
time what I eat I'm still hungry
drinking for relating to myself it's
about knowing who you are in 2018 you
guys just be you then we get into
crystal again and she is fun to watch I
will give her that she's now Corinne but
she's fun to watch so she's like asking
everybody else like wouldn't you think
if your time with re which I find to be
really upper critical since I think on
the last episode she said she didn't
want to get too into her time with re
with the other girls that is a villain
[Music]
hypocrisy so and then we get this
fabulous monologue from Crystal where
she talks about like how her life has
been so hard because like her boyfriend
broke up with her so we did Amy she
wouldn't eat him cuz she's my best
friend which I'm gonna talk about how
other women are so jealous of me in this
like breathy voice and talk about like
my 8th grade best friend who wouldn't be
friends than because her boyfriend
wanted to date me and it's just like I
have struggled so much like I would say
the 99.9 percent of women's boyfriends
want to date mean it's just like I've
had to bear that bird dip
not drinking because I relate to that
just drinking okay so Ari is going on a
one-on-one and I don't know who this
girl is
I'm going on a date today she seems to
get a little bit of a recycled date from
crystal because it looks like that same
plane with that same red carpet round
two you know I don't know maybe you
booked those planes for a certain amount
of timing like we gotta use it we paid
for the gas you could go home so I hope
you got a lock and it's like sure yeah
we all do and I'm gonna drink when I was
relating to this girl because first I
found out her name was Lauren she's one
of the Lauren's so I can relate hmm
thank God Ari said Lauren asked like
four times because I'm like I don't know
who this girl yes you know we're still
in that phase where like we don't know
who a lot of these girls are and then
she said that their date which turned
out to be a trip to Napa to wine country
was the key to her heart yes girl hmm I
mean I mean I mean yeah and you know
what why don't they let the girls
suggest or pick out a date that would be
fun surprise the lead switch it up okay
that is a good suggestion I'm gonna
tweet some people I like my idea
relating to myself by the way you guys I
mean there have been 22 seasons of The
Bachelor alone if there has a date that
you've never seen on the show that you'd
like to see because how many private
planes can we get into and how many
barrels of grapes can we stop in wine
country please leave it in the comments
below I'd love to know and then they
actually have some cute conversation and
are I mean me laugh he's like the older
I get the more I want to go to bed
earlier and wearing cardigans how relate
to that Ari I mean I'm in a sweater
while filming a video I mean
and then things took a surprising turn I
thought they were going really well but
Lauren s just keeps talking and talking
and weird of vomiting and she tried to
save it at the end by saying she didn't
know why she'd been so not herself but
she had to go I like that about our er
he's not playing around if he does not
feel it with you you got to go you do
not get that ro and hurries reasoning
was really it's Dearing know cuz he's
like I just think you know she's been
going on and I'm not about her family
he's like I just think if you want to if
you like your family so much I don't
want to take you away from what could be
at home I don't want to keep you from
them it wasn't that you were going on
and I'm not it was that you won't about
your family okay okay
oh and I mean you could tell how bored
are you was because he just started
eating on the date I called my mom on
Mother's Day and they never eat on the
dates he was like I've been here a while
oh honey get some protein I relate
mm-hmm
eat on a date who's been on a bad date
and just kept ordering food protip okay
then a group date and they find out it's
about dogs and everyone is cheering for
dogs
I don't relate to this I don't do well
with pets of animals I don't do well
with living things that rely on other
living things yes okay and Annalise we
said we'd get back to her so she had
that bumper car trauma and could it
barely handle the demolition derby date
and now she says in my childhood I had a
traumatic experience with the dog quote
several traumatic instances with dogs
and again these editors gave us a
beautiful reenactment today I don't know
where they got this footage of angry
little dog I was trying to think like
what something in my own childhood that
is just so bizarre that really
traumatized me
and you know what I came up with dream
catchers in the third grade and this is
Herbert's class we had to make dream
catchers and it involves like a lot of
like crossing or Blake I believe fishing
line and I couldn't do it very well and
so that's right none of my dreams have
been caught
[Applause]
Oh also can I note as Lauren s was being
sent home
I believe Claire de Lune was playing Wow
The Bachelor up in the production budget
elevating the content taking things to a
cinematic level I mean that music was
used at the ending of Ocean's eleven
Wow
or maybe like I don't know the music's
free I don't really know I know who owns
the rights so that it's probably mean
like 1895 or something okay
why is 1895 my go-to year for old stuff
anyway oh wait no joke just clearing the
throat by the way a very strong reaction
to Lauren s going home people were
gasping there were tears and Krystal was
there to say I only tried to talk to her
and tell her she open up you're like if
you're not gonna open up but this
serious re is her eyes were scaring the
crap out of me during that moment and a
girl who I don't know was like how could
crystal say that crystal just think
sorry is her man you know like after
this one one-on-one she had with him
they have bonded or she's like he's mine
just the process it has to be done I
know professed to be together I gave her
credit for being interesting TV in that
regard I thought the dog show was really
funny they had Fred Willard on it and if
you guys don't know it's because he was
in the comedy Best in Show which is a
legendary comedy he's a legendary
comedian check it out
soap box off I'm done ari says that he
dated people who weren't ready for
marriage as a defense mechanism
that is interesting and I see it because
we've heard so much that he was never
over Emily and but we know that he dated
other people and now are he's owning up
to why I kind of like that maybe from
here things will launch into some more
real trauma you know not bumper car dog
trauma but like some real crap because
that's what makes this show good a
combination of insanity and deep reality
he definitely planned something really
special for Ari
Bibiana is planning something private
towards the end of the group date
because she is our Maxine Waters she is
reclaiming her time I'm reclaiming my
time please Viviana wants her time with
Ari so she plans some kind of like
daybed telescope situation and then
she's still like I'm gonna be patient no
girl don't be patient reclaim your time
reclaim our time and other girls and re
literally start like getting on the bed
they're like who set this up I don't
know well this is great let's sing out
here and I don't think Viviana ever got
any time on the David thanks Beca
analyzes Ari she's like you date women
need you yes it's getting deeper I like
Becca I do
she might be 22 but she's got a lot to
say to you Ari
and she's like maybe that's why you like
moms cuz they need you remind her no I
thought he had a good reaction to that I
would have been a little bit like hey
whoa but she was I guess he did I guess
he reacted so positively cuz she was
right okay and then Annalise is trying
to recruit lis reclaim her time and
reclaim her trauma by getting a kiss
from Ari and she protects her Yanks
pillow lips I said I wouldn't said it
and I said it said I wouldn't say it I
said whatever pillow lips said no to a
kiss from Annalise and man so we've just
given her yet another trauma from bumper
cars two dogs two rejections she's got
some adult trauma to talk about at least
I guess
yikes okay so after all this Ari tells
you know Annalise to go home so at the
rose ceremony
Bibiana is the only person sent home
this poor woman who's just been trying
to get her time and she's like why do
people come at me with arguments and yet
I gotta be patient she's the only one
sent home girl and she says she's broken
viviana you are not broken you take that
telescope and you look to your future
and it is bright okay
you have that bed as your own and you go
to sleep and wake up and think about a
new tomorrow okay 2018 my love the way
re sends people home you know I think he
told her like get home safe
he is he's like that dad he's like
texting when you get home you know let
me know if you don't if you have a drink
call me I'll pick you up for a ride okay
yeah all right that guy I know I can
okay so we didn't see much of Becca with
two sees and remember JC and Josue had
their big debate about the Becca's last
week we didn't see much of Becca to C's
but well we did see her and Arie had
some nice moments and I'll have you
seemed to agree with those way that re
buying her all those dresses meant he
wants to see her and all those dresses
and so there's a future there it seems
from the preview that next week you're
going to find out Becca's age on camera
and I don't know how are you going to
react to this
you don't know let's just finish this
just like baby on it tried to finish it
okay I can't wait to say it's time for
winter games I'm so excited you guys
please let me know as always what you
thought of this episode of The Bachelor
and as I said before overall what you're
thinking of this season is it good are
you bored
is it nice and real or is it to not
dramatic let me know have a great night
everybody
stay warm babe